¿Qué sucedió?
Cayla fue prohibida en Alemania,
salió de los estantes en Amazon y Wal-Mart,
y ahora descansa en paz
en el German Spy Museum en Berlín.
(Risas)
Sin embargo, Cayla también estuvo a la venta alrededor del mundo
durante más de un año luego de que publicamos el informe.
Lo que descubrimos es que hay pocas reglas para protegernos
y las que tenemos no se cumplen adecuadamente.
Tenemos que corregir la seguridad y privacidad de estos dispositivos
antes de que salgan al mercado,
porque ¿qué sentido tiene cerrar una casa con llave
si cualquiera puede entrar a través de un dispositivo conectado?
Podrán pensar, "Esto no me va a pasar.
Me voy a mantener alejado de estos dispositivos fallados".
Pero eso no los mantendrá seguros,
porque conectándose a internet
están en una posición imposible de tómalo o déjalo.
Déjenme mostrarles.
Como muchos de Uds. tengo docenas de aplicaciones en mi teléfono
y si las usamos adecuadamente, pueden hacernos la vida más fácil,
más práctica y hasta más saludable.
Pero ¿hemos sido llevados a un falso sentido de seguridad?
Comienza simplemente tildando un cuadro.
Sí, decimos,
he leído los términos.
Pero ¿realmente han leído los términos?
¿Están seguros de que no parecían muy largos
y su teléfono se quedaba sin batería
y la última vez que intentaron eran imposibles de entender,
y necesitaban usar ya el servicio?
Ahora, el poder de desequilibrio está establecido
porque aceptamos que nuestra información personal
se recolecte y utilice a una escala que nunca imaginamos.
Es por esto que mis colegas y yo decidimos observar más en profundidad.
Nos dispusimos a leer los términos
de aplicaciones populares en un teléfono regular.
Y para mostrarle al mundo cuán poco realista
es esperar que los consumidores realmente lean los términos,
los imprimimos,
más de 900 páginas,
y nos sentamos en la oficina y los leímos en voz alta,
transmitiendo el experimento en vivo en nuestros sitios web.
Como verán, llevó mucho tiempo.
Nos llevó 31 horas, 49 minutos y 11 segundos
leer los términos en un teléfono promedio.
Eso es más tiempo que una maratón de las películas de "Harry Potter"
y "El padrino" combinadas.
(Risas)
Y leerlo es una cosa.
Entenderlo es otra historia.
Eso nos hubiera llevado mucho, mucho más tiempo.
Esto es un verdadero problema
porque las compañías han discutido por 20 o 30 años
contra una mejor regulación de internet
porque los usuarios han consentido los términos y condiciones.
Como demostramos con este experimento,
lograr consentimiento informado es casi imposible.
¿Creen que es justo poner la carga de la responsabilidad en el consumidor?
Yo no.
Creo que debemos demandar menos tómalo o déjalo
y más términos entendibles antes de aceptarlos.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Ahora quiero contarles una historia sobre el amor.
Algunas de las aplicaciones más populares del mundo son las de citas,
una industria que ahora vale más, o cerca, de 3 mil millones al año.
Por supuesto, estamos bien compartiendo nuestros detalles íntimos
con nuestra otra mitad.
Pero ¿quién más está husmeando,
guardando y compartiendo nuestra información
mientras desnudamos nuestras almas?
Mi equipo y yo decidimos investigar esto.
Para entender el asunto desde todos los ángulos,
y para hacer realmente un trabajo minucioso,
me di cuenta de que tenía que descargar
una de las aplicaciones de citas más populares del mundo.
Así que fui a hablar con mi esposa...
(Risas)
con la que me acababa de casar.
"¿Está bien si me creo un perfil en una aplicación de citas muy popular
con fines puramente científicos?".
(Risas)
Esto es lo que encontramos.
Oculto detrás del menú principal había un cuadro pretildado
que le daba a la compañía de citas acceso a mis fotos en Facebook,
en mi caso más de 2000,
y algunas eran muy personales.
Más grave aún,
cuando leímos los términos y condiciones
descubrimos lo siguiente,
y voy a necesitar sacar mis anteojos de lectura para esto.
Se los voy a leer porque es complicado.
De acuerdo.
"Al publicar contenido"...
y contenido se refiere a fotos, charlas
y otras interacciones en el servicio de citas,
"como parte del servicio,
Ud. automáticamente le concede a la compañía,
sus afiliados, titulares y sucesores
un irrevocable", lo que significa que no pueden cambiar de idea,
"perpetuo", que significa para siempre,
"no exclusivo, transferible, sublicenciable, completamente saldado,
derecho mundial y licencia para usar, copiar, almacenar,
exhibir, reproducir, registrar,
emitir, adaptar, modificar y distribuir el contenido,
preparar trabajos derivados del contenido,
o incorporar el contenido en otros trabajos
y conceder y autorizar sublicencias del precedente en cualquier medio
ahora conocido o creado en adelante".
Eso básicamente significa que todo tu historial de citas
y lo relacionado con ello puede usarse con cualquier fin para siempre.
Imaginen a sus hijos viendo sus fotos de citas atrevidas
en un comercial de anticonceptivos dentro de 20 años.
Pero de verdad,
(Risas)
¿qué significarían estas prácticas comerciales?
Por ejemplo, pérdida financiera:
basándonos en tu historial web,
los algoritmos pueden decidir si obtendrás una hipoteca o no.
Manipulación subconsciente:
las compañías pueden analizar tus emociones basados en fotos y charlas
y enviarte publicidades cuando estás más vulnerable.
Discriminación:
una aplicación de salud puede vender tu información a una compañía de seguros
evitando que obtengas cobertura en el futuro.
Todo esto sucede hoy en el mundo.
Pero claro, no todos los usos de información son malignos.
Algunos tienen fallas o necesitan más trabajo,
y algunos son increíbles.
Y también hay buenas noticias.
Las compañías de citas cambiaron su política a nivel mundial
luego de que presentáramos una denuncia legal.
Pero las organizaciones como la mía
que luchan por los derechos del consumidor no pueden estar en todas partes.
Y los consumidores no pueden arreglar esto por su cuenta,
porque si sabemos que algo inocente que dijimos
volverá para perseguirnos,
dejaríamos de hablar.
Si supiéramos que nos observan y nos monitorean,
cambiaríamos nuestro comportamiento.
Y si no podemos controlar quién tiene nuestra información y cómo se utiliza,
hemos perdido el control de nuestra vida.
Las historias que les conté hoy no son ejemplos al azar.
Están en todos lados
y son una señal de que las cosas deben cambiar.
¿Cómo podemos lograr ese cambio?
Las compañías deben darse cuenta
de que al darle prioridad a la privacidad y la seguridad
se ganarán la confianza y lealtad de sus usuarios.
Los gobiernos deben crear una internet más segura
asegurando la imposición y actualización de normas.
¿Y los ciudadanos?
Podemos usar nuestra voz
para recordarle al mundo que la tecnología solo puede beneficiar a la sociedad
si respeta los derechos básicos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)